lawyers for actress Lauri Lachlan and
her husband claimed new evidence shows
the couple is innocent in the College
Admission scandal and illegal filing
defense attorneys say prosecutors
provided them with notes written by the
admitted ringleader of the scheme Ric
singer
they say the notes prove the couple's
claim that they did not bribe their
daughter's way the University of
Southern California
Nikki petit joins us with the latest on
the story Nikki good morning why is this
information coming out now good morning
Tony well federal prosecutors say they
discovered singer's personal notes back
in October 2018 but believed they were
privileged at the time and held off on
disclosing them until yesterday
now Laughlin's lawyers argue those notes
and what they say about investigators
conduct could exonerate the defendants
it's been nearly a year since Ric singer
pleaded guilty to charges including
racketeering and fraud as part of an
alleged scheme to buy students admission
to top-tier colleges but a new memo from
defense attorneys for Lachlan and her
husband Massimo Jia newly claims the
government instructed singer to lie to
clients by calling their payments bribes
even if he'd previously characterized
them as legitimate the memo contains a
note singer wrote on his iPhone about
his discussions with FBI agents in what
exchange he called loud and abrasive
singer said they continue to ask me to
tell a fib and not restate what I told
my clients as to where the money was
going
Lachlan ng a newly paid half a million
dollars to USC allegedly so their
daughters could attend the school
they've insisted the money was a
donation but they're accused of taking
additional measures to cheat the system
like making a fake resume for one of
their kids
this comes after other defendants caught
up in singers web-like fellow Hollywood
actress Felicity Huffman not only
pleaded guilty but finished serving
prison sentences that includes former
New York attorney Gordon Kaplan who
admitted he paid $75,000 to have the
answers on his daughter's a CT exam
corrected in his notes singer wrote that
investigators wanted to quote nail
Gordon at all costs and asked him to
solicit additional payments from Kaplan
for that purpose it's an embarrassment
for the government Laurie Levenson is a
former federal prosecutor
she says singers notes should have been
turned over long ago and they bring both
his and the government's credibility
into question it gives the defense some
ammunition to say that in fact Laughlin
others didn't really agree that this was
a bribe this is a positive development
for Lori Loughlin we don't know whether
it will clear her or make the case go
away but we do know that it puts the
government on the defensive a judge was
set to decide trial dates for Lachlan
and other figures implicated in the
scandal today but her defense team is
asking for that proceeding to be pushed
back in light of the new information
detailed in singer's notes they call the
government's previous failure to
disclose those notes outrageous was
actually speaking with our legal analyst
Ricky Clement who says for Lori Lachlan
there's still really no way around the
fact that she made fraudulent resumes
with dummy photos to make her daughter
look like the athlete that she isn't
yeah it does paint another side but at
the end of today you do as Ricky points
out have those pictures yes you fake the
recipe hard to explain that one all
right Nikki all right thanks Nikki